[Música]
a samuel para ti lo mataron precisamente
por todo esto
por que personificó el renacimiento de
la república cada día en cada aula en la
libertad que se transmite y que se
perpetúa en las escuelas
samuel para ti fue asesinado porque los
islamistas quieren nuestro futuro
islamista
y ellos estoy convencido que con héroes
silenciosos como él nunca lo tendrán y
lo llame
y clear hemos dicho claramente y
seguiremos diciendo que la libertad que
permite a un dibujante hacer caricaturas
no obliga a los musulmanes de francia a
amar estás sátiras incluso pueden odiar
las pero absolutamente nada puede
justificar matar o dañar la integridad
física de un hombre por haber
caricaturizado
es muy importante venir aquí para
mostrar nuestro dolor para decir que lo
que pasó no fue el islam es el trabajo
de matones que no tienen nada que ver
con nuestra religión porque nuestro
credo nos pide que trabajemos para hacer
que la gente viva no para matarla de
trabajo por servirles a europa bien y
dan barber estas son señales de que
occidente se encamina una vez más hacia
un periodo de barbarie francia y europa
en general no merecen las políticas de
manjón y aquellos con mentalidades
similares que esparcen semillas de odio
hasta el museo living en jean ofendió a
todos los musulmanes cómo se puede
insultar al profeta
esto significa que makro no ofendió a
todos los musulmanes por eso todos
debemos unirnos y boicotear sus
productos esto es lo menos que podemos
hacer
esto no tiene nada que ver con la
libertad macro un habla de libertad y no
tiene nada que ver con eso la libertad
está en lo que es justo han insultado
una figura en el islam que es intocable
el profeta no estamos hablando de otros
humanos además la política no debería
tener nada que ver con las religiones
porque apoya a las caricaturas que
ofenden al profeta esta no debería ser
una posición para un presidente el
presidente debe exigir que no se insulte
a ninguna religión dentro y sea fútbol
y legal ahora los nuevos ataques a la
libertad de expresión vienen de una
parte desde la existencia de las redes
sociales que se movilizan cuando algo no
les gusta y ese no es el problema eso
también es libertad de expresión incluso
cuando no nos gusta lo que escuchamos el
problema es que utilizan amenazas
intimidaciones e incluso amenazas de
muerte lo que claramente es inadmisible
y es algo que puede crear tormentas
alrededor de un dibujante de prensa
[Música]